hey everyone it's unishek here and
welcome to a halo infinite development
update today we're going to be talking
about the recent tech preview with a
live producer sam hanshaw and then we're
going to be jumping on board with skech
and joseph staton to hear more about the
road to launch before we dive into it
though i want to preface that we won't
have any new gameplay but we will have a
ton of good information to talk about so
with that housekeeping out of the way uh
sam how's it going you know uh pretty
well to be honest i'm really excited to
talk about what we learned during the
tech preview i think the
fans were pretty excited to get their
hands on the game and so
probably equally excited to find out
what we learned from them getting the
hands on the game so tech preview went
out we thought it was pretty darn
successful from your perspective how'd
it go yeah it was a success we had some
problems along the way getting there but
it's important to have those kinds of
problems because those are the things
that we want to address now rather than
have them crop up as a surprise at
launch yeah and that's kind of why we
started testing at such a large scale
already so early so this was
obviously our first big scale flight
we've done it was a global release to
hundreds of thousands of people
and
those people did
over a million
bot matches and they also participated
in weapon drills over two million times
and probably most importantly for me
is they filed thousands of support
tickets
yeah and that's good to hear because we
want player feedback not only about the
game but also on the state of the game
so that we can continue to improve and
iterate on the road to launch
yeah absolutely and kind of speaking of
those learnings right that we're getting
from those tickets
overall what were some of the key
learnings from the flight
sure so
we know we had a lot of pain around
getting into the flight initially
so
we know we had some issues on the halo
insider side that we're working on um we
also had some problems getting in
through the xbox insider hub on console
and we've been working in close
partnership with the xbox insider hub
team and we're working on some solutions
to that and ways that we can mitigate
that for the future so on top of
waypoint
and xbox insider we also got a lot of
feedback around the pc and console kind
of optimization and how it ran
on those machines do you have any info
you can share there yeah so
starting off with pc this was our first
time flying to so many different
hardware configurations and we uncovered
some issues
one of the things that was um
pretty painful for everyone was we had
like a misconfiguration in
uh how the exe was running and that was
resulting in about a 20 performance drop
um that's been addressed on our side and
so for the next release you can expect
at least a 20 improvement in performance
um we also had specific problems with
gtx 900 series graphics cards you know
these are things that
come out when we have
more people participating in the flights
and things and we get to see a lot more
of the hardware configurations so that's
something that pc teams working on
actively
and as of all things with both pc and
console we're going to see a lot of
performance boosts over the next couple
of months and a quick reminder to
everyone that this build that we
flighted for tech pvp was about two
months old and so stepping back to kind
of the trunk of development it's like
going in a time machine and since it was
a two-month-old build right we've
already addressed numerous things with
stability and loading issues right i
know loading issues were a common thing
in this flight yeah they were
we know that in addition to getting into
the flight getting into matches was a
bit of a bit of a struggle so match
loading had some inconsistencies some
folks would drop out of matchmaking
every now and again some folks dropped
out consistently
and
while that did cause a lot of pain for
folks it also helped us get a lot of
data so that we could address those
issues and going back to the main dev
branch i've had folks working on it and
now people are getting into matches
super consistently
so much much better already yeah right
and we also have a new loading screen i
heard right yeah that's true there's
nothing worse than getting kicked out of
matchmaking
except getting kicked out of matchmaking
when all you've had to look at is a
black screen with three dots so now we
got some nice new loading screens people
look at
that they should be seeing for a lot
less time than they saw the black screen
too it's a nice new loading screen but
less time to actually see it yeah so
once people got in past the loading
screen we had bot matches for them and
weapon drills for them with a little bit
of pvp for two hours
what was the reasoning behind choosing
bots and weapon drills so the boston
weapon drills are two key pieces of our
new player onboarding and so
having players experience that for the
first time in our first kind of public
flight like this was really important
because we get that initial feedback of
what it's like to pick up this game and
learn it through the weapon drills and
through bar play one other thing that we
get from flighting
using the bot matches
is
we only have four people in each match
so we have to spin up a dedicated server
for every four people who are on so
essentially by doing this we doubled our
server strain for this audience size so
this increases our confidence for
shipping and releasing to larger and
larger audiences so we know with the
hundreds of thousands of people who we
invited
for this tech preview when we did it
with bots the week can handle twice that
many people at least
with pvp
that's really cool actually uh i
remember
people were talking about why bots why
weapon drills so thank you for diving
into that oh no problem yeah and i think
that the bots kind of
showed up well you know
i know we got a lot of good comments and
good feedback on how the bots behave and
a lot of the feedback that people gave
you know that's being incorporated too
yeah people were intimidated by the bots
which is really cool to see
up next we also had a few people talk
about the halo support site kind of
closing down at the at the very end of
the flight right right as we cut off the
flight we also closed off the halo
support site uh and i know that's
something we were looking to change
moving forward yeah i mean
that's one of those things where like in
hindsight
it makes total sense everyone wants to
play until the last minute of the flight
and when it closes down they're going to
head on over to to file the bugs they
don't want to waste their flight time
filing bugs so now we're going to be
keeping that support site open past the
end of the flight so that the people who
were dedicated and playing the entire
time not one to dip out of any of the
halo action they can file their bugs at
the end we do recommend that you know
you keep a notebook so that you've got
you've got your bugs fresh when they
happen because there's nothing worse
than hitting some game breaking bug and
then forgetting about it two hours later
because you've had too much fun playing
halo
too much fun playing halo no such thing
so looking ahead on the road to launch
what do we have next for flighting you
can definitely expect another big scale
flight like this with even more people
invited we're gonna include the same
content that we had this time the bots
and the weapon drills but we're also
targeting a full release of 4v4 pvp
action
and we want to go even bigger and have
big team battle so those are our targets
for the next flight to come
nice and then once we get to launch we
also have hopes anticipations to flight
features and and content beyond right
yeah absolutely this fighting program
that we're kicking off now obviously
we're gearing it towards getting those
bugs and that feedback for launch
but
halo infinite is a game that's going to
go on and when we have new features
um that we want to test we're going to
do it in the same fashion so we're
setting up this program to be
lasting through beyond launch
nice yeah so people need to make sure
they're registered for the halo insider
program over on halo waypoint so that
they can participate in this upcoming
big team battle flight as well as the uh
flights that we'll have beyond launch
right yeah absolutely if you haven't
signed up for halo insider profile and
completed all of the steps then
why are you watching this video for
go do it go do it
so sam thank you so much for joining us
today uh before we wrap up our segment
uh did you have any closing words that
you'd like to say to the community yeah
i mean
thank you uni for having me here um
thank you people in the community those
who participate in the flight those
who've signed it up signed up for halo
insider truly like
this success is yours and this is the
beginning of our conversation with you
and we couldn't be happier to kick it
off in this fashion i also want to say a
thanks to the folks who aren't in the
studio today like so many people worked
on this tech preview to get it out to
everyone um
and they've been working hard on all the
feedback and bugs that we got from this
so
a huge thanks to like all those folks
i'm
just a guy who gets to sit in a chair
and talk about it really
and the team deserves all the things in
the world for delivering what they did
to our players
yeah i could not agree more i do want to
address that we know that there's quite
a few halo players that want to know
what happened to their feedback that
they left on the forums on twitter sent
to the community team directly and we
will have a blog coming up on waypoint
here in the next few weeks so make sure
you stay tuned for that and as always
make sure you're registered for the halo
insider program so you can participate
in these upcoming tech previews now
we're going to toss it on over to brian
aka sketch and joseph staton to hear
more about halo infinite and the road to
launch
hey everyone sketch here from 343
industries we are in the hub at our
studio in redmond washington and i am
joined today by halo infinite's head of
creative joseph staton joseph how you
doing good i'm doing well thank you for
inviting me to the hub i mean before we
get too far ahead i just want to call
out serious deja vu right now and
interestingly enough as i've been
thinking about this more
i know you joined 343 kind of came back
to halo last fall but this is the first
time you and i have been kind of side by
side talking about halo together since
2009
with a little game that you were working
on called halo 3 odst oh that's straight
to the heart that's right man that was a
long time ago it was and you know just
to make sure we've all got the mental
image of kind of what that was like back
then and how far we've come
i found some b-roll that i kind of want
to make sure the community had a chance
to just remember the good old days so
let's take a quick look at that what if
the phones rang oh yes what i i think we
know the phones did ring right joseph
and yes of course back then the
community had a lot of fun in the early
days of of memery
with that little freeze frame face
i want to point out though like what 12
years later i'm getting a very similar
vibe from another recent meme our
community created i just want to give
you a chance to check this out i think
you might have been the inspiration for
this
yeah i gotta say i do befuddled very
well just that
well i mean here we are again
12 years later things have changed they
kind of haven't though right no i mean
here we are two grizzled ancients
getting back together again talking
about halo but
you know brian fair's fair i'm not the
only one with 2009 archival footage
sitting around so let's take a little
peek at that
hey and if i'm not mistaken like is that
is that the same coat in that photo
today what can i say i've
defrosted you like encino man and
brought you brought you out it is i mean
my hair has continued to grow but i've
been preserved in stasis it's funny this
jacket's seen a lot of mileage it's been
around
you know looking at that photograph wait
sorry look at that photograph
oh well played yeah the trap was just
there and we sprung it
yes you gotta love our community and the
jokes and yes my hair has grown a lot
and uh brian it looks it looks fantastic
not gonna lie it looks good although i
think the the sad thing is back in 2009
like you had way
less hair and i had way more hair so
clearly like a good decade of game
development will will age you or maybe
not maybe not depends i don't know i
think you look pretty much the same it's
just that youthful vigor
halo of just halo is life right so
joseph let's just jump right into this
we just heard from sam and john
as you know we wrapped up our big giant
milestone for our first multiplayer tech
preview how do things go kind of what
are your key takeaways from your
perspective well first of all i just got
to say it was awesome to have thousands
of people just jump in and play i mean
as you know the team's been working on
this game for a long time but getting a
whole bunch of players to jump in see
what we've been working on check out new
maps mix it up with the bots even get in
a little bit of pvp which was awesome
that excitement to see our fans having
fun was just a huge emotional lift for
everybody at 343
and on the flip side just getting honest
unvarnished feedback from fans whether
it was login bugs or uh posting detailed
videos on youtube we just generated a
ton of actionable feedback on things
that we still needed to work on and
parts of the game that were that were
missing the fans were curious about um
and speaking of which one of the things
that people wanted to know about was
split screen right i mean playing halo
competitive multiplayer on a couch with
your family and friends split screen has
always been a super core part of the
halo experience and we just want to
reassure people that although we didn't
have split screen multiplayer in the
tech preview we will absolutely be
shipping that day one for launch on all
xbox family devices
on pc it's a slightly different story
there are just technical challenges
around pc with a whole bunch of
different configs and other issues so
we're not going to have split screen
multiplayer on pc for launch but it's
absolutely something the team's excited
about exploring post launch okay joseph
well thanks for touching on uh pc
multiplayer split screen in particular
that's something that we've had
questions about you know just a lot of
feedback obviously even through mcc you
know which has been a great way for us
to learn and gather additional feedback
but on that topic you know you
referenced a lot of feedback from the
tech preview
we still have so much that we're sorting
through together right so the community
team the support team the development
team yeah kind of actively working
through that process where we identify
all the different sort of key themes
that we've heard and then
work together with all the different
leads and stakeholders to determine kind
of
how to action on these and how to
prioritize them but i did kind of want
to be clear for expectation setting that
there's only so much that we're going to
be able to action on now um but that's
the beauty of being a live service yeah
absolutely i think you know a lot of
people play in the tech preview or you
know any of that you know pre-release
look at the game and wonder hey if i
participate and i provide feedback you
know how much of this is actually going
to be acted on by the development team
you know when it comes to the technical
preview that's exactly what it was we
wanted thousands of people to jump in
bang on it help us identify what's wrong
and like you said we're actioning on a
ton of feedback from that test it was
super useful and yes some of the things
we won't be able to do for launch but
you're right that's part of being a
service and the good news is we have a
year-long post-launch content and
feature roadmap already worked out you
know we're already working on those
things now so yeah some things won't
land in a launch time frame but some
things you know will just roll out over
time that's part of this halo infinite
journey that we're kicking off together
with fans joseph you know as part of
this live service and this journey that
we're going to be kicking off this
holiday not only is it
exciting and important to think about
new experiences new content
but that relationship with our community
and not only the feedback but
our ability and our commitment to being
open and honest and just sort of making
sure that we're in this together yeah um
absolutely so to that end one of the
reasons that we're here today as well is
i want to talk to you about the campaign
side of the game specifically
campaign co-op like multiplayer is this
burning heart of halo campaign co-op is
fundamental to the halo experience as
well i actually know if i told you this
brian but my son and i in a failure of
parenting i have not played legendary
halo with my son he's 19 now so a couple
weeks ago we started playing campaign
co-op legendary together we just beat
halo 2.
the jackal snipers are still a delight
and i just had a ton of fun and it
reminded me just how essential that
experience of playing campaign together
with your family and friends whether
networked or split screen really is
unfortunately as we focus the team for
shutdown and really focused on a quality
experience for launch we made the really
tough decision to delay
shipping campaign co-op for launch and
we also made the tough call to delay
shipping forge past launch as well well
joseph i mean clearly this is not a
decision that you or the team takes is
taken lightly right i mean we know this
is a
just an integral part of the halo
experience so can you just talk through
a little bit of kind of just the why
like how why is why was this decision
you know you and i talk about this a lot
and everybody in the studio has the same
conversation which is what is our number
one priority well our number one
priority is making sure that whatever we
ship whenever we ship it it meets the
right quality bar
across all platforms xbox devices pc and
all its different configurations and
when we looked at these two experiences
campaign co-op and forge we made the
determination they're just not
ready you know and as a studio we don't
want to ship things if they're not ready
so people can play them have fun have a
nice stable performance experience so
we're going to keep camping co-op and
forge in the oven for a little bit
longer and then when they're ready we're
going to release them as part of our
seasonal roadmap next year
so i want to talk about the roadmap in
just a second but i do want to
acknowledge it's a little
it's a little awkward we're talking
about things that are in for launch and
like right frankly we don't have an
official public launch date yet that is
true that is true but i did want to just
reconfirm and as we heard phil spencer i
think he made a reference recently like
this game is definitely we're committed
to releasing this holiday yes and we're
pretty close i think to we're just
working through some details right now
on kind of what that real date is right
yes that is absolutely correct we are
100 committed to releasing this holiday
both
campaign and our first season of free to
play multiplayer we just have to like
you said work through a couple more
details and we'll be talking about our
actual release date very soon so as we
look at beyond launch to be on this
holiday at our seasonal road map what
kind of timing should we be thinking
about in terms of co-op and forge coming
to halo infinite what we're targeting is
to ship campaign co-op uh in season two
and then we're targeting to ship forge
in season
three and i know as we talk about
seasons i should probably explain that a
little bit i think for anybody who's
been reading our
blogs or has been engaged in master
chief collection or frankly has been
playing any other live game they're
probably pretty familiar with the way
seasons work but timing wise for us a
season is about three months that's our
goal is to ship a season every three
months so when it comes to campaign
co-op
our target is to ship co-op in season
two about three months after launch and
then our goal is to ship forge in season
three which would be about six months
after launch but of course all these
plans are subject to change as we dial
things in but that's our goal right now
for sure and you know part of having
this open and honest dialogue with our
community is as
the game team makes progress and
development moves forward we'll be able
to provide updates and just sort of keep
keep folks uh abreast of how things are
going also should give a shout out that
my understanding is uh halo insiders
would have the opportunity to
participate in some hands-on forge ahead
of release through fighting similar to
how we've been doing the tech preview
for multiplayer this year yep that's
absolutely right and i think when it
comes to forge i mean maybe just a
little bit more context for people to
understand why we're taking a little bit
more time with it so the forge tool is
amazing i mean i was around at the
beginning of forge and to see how it's
progressed is is really really cool and
i can't wait to see what people begin to
create with it but as a tool set it's
really advanced and it's going to
hopefully give people the ability to
create a whole bunch of new innovative
novel experiences but again their
technical complexities they're just
going to take time to get it right and
on the co-op side i mean
we have the opportunity to play campaign
all the time it's this wonderful
wide open
non-linear take on a halo campaign and
it's going to offer so much more
flexibility to you know take down
banished bases from all kinds of
different angles to progress through the
game in a in your own way to a certain
extent and at the same time though
that's complicated when you think about
save systems and all the technology that
needs to drive this more non-linear
experience so in the co-op scenario
that's even more complicated and that's
another reason why it's going to take
longer just to make sure
it's quality day one and people can jump
in and play and have fun
so speaking of things taking a little
more time yeah i have to ask uh you know
as you and the team were reviewing the
status of co-op and forge was there ever
discussion about potentially
delaying the entire game and taking more
time
to get these in first
yeah i mean we talked about doing that
but where we landed was you know halo
infinite is a live
game so it isn't really ever
done you know what i mean it's going to
progress and evolve from season to
season we talk about launch being the
beginning of that journey but to have a
beginning you need to
pick a moment and actually begin you
know so ultimately we decided
we've been working on this game for a
really long time our fans have been
waiting for this game for a really long
time with solo campaign and our first
season of free to play multiplayer in
really good shape for holiday we didn't
want to delay anymore let's get started
and you know we'll continue to evolve
from there season season so what is the
team
actively like working on right now like
what is what is the focus between now
and launch so the team is in what we
call shutdown mode and what that means
is essentially a lot of bug fixing a lot
of reviewing the game playing looking at
areas where we still need work whether
it's on campaign or on multiplayer
and again the goal is to make sure that
on day one we deliver an awesome
experience whether you're playing on an
eight-year-old xbox one or a brand new
cutting edge pc so yeah we're in review
mode really taking a close look at the
game in the shutdown or polish period
and actually something really wonderful
has been happening recently where for
the first time in a very long time we've
been able to gather together safely in
person and sit down and review the game
together and we recorded some some
footage of that happening so let's show
that and people can get a sense of kind
of how it looks like inside the studio
now as we shut down the game yeah i mean
this is a behind-the-scenes look raw
right i mean this is this is raw trench
footage and yeah i mean it looks like we
just like evacuated yeah and we're just
now kind of coming back into this vacant
sort of semi-trashed environment right
yeah i mean i mean with kovid we did
kind of evacuate the studio and for a
long time i mean you know brian it was
almost impossible to safely gather and
just sit down and review the game
together and that was super strange and
super stressful because game creation is
highly collaborative so look it's just a
huge relief to be vaccinated and now do
what we've always done at this phase in
a project which is sit down and play i
mean it sounds so simple but it's like a
miracle that we're able to do this again
joseph i definitely i mean we have to
give a huge shout out i mean you know
how incredibly challenging this period
has been and just you know it is amazing
to see people finally being able to come
back and lean in but yeah just the fact
that you know removing all the desks and
creating a safe spaced out you know
environment to be able to do this in or
empowering the team to remote work and
have the pipelines and infrastructure i
mean
so many people have worked so hard to
allow this work to continue 100 and what
you don't see in that uh footage that we
showed i mean you saw all the four tvs
set up you know with different consoles
plugged in tv different pcs plugged in
you know reviewing the game across all
platforms at the same time but you only
saw the people in the room that there's
actually a teams meeting happening with
like 30 or 40 people in the background
all watching screens you know pausing
saying hey wait you know go to xbox one
i want to like look at that specifically
so it's this huge
infrastructure effort i.t effort just
coming together across the entire studio
all teams to make it happen and i'm just
so thankful to the team working so hard
to get this done and like we said it's
it's a little weird but it feels it
feels great we're shipping the game
all right so we are in shutdown mode
road to launch is in full swing
of course everyone wants to know when
can we see and hear more about this game
everybody wants to see campaign
especially campaign gameplay we will
absolutely show campaign gameplay before
launch but we just need to stay focused
on shutdown mode once we're past that
hurdle you know we're going to be going
after things like
gameplay captures and trailers that will
all be coming a little bit closer to
launch
you know possible could just give us a
little tease could i ask about craig
everyone wants to know
anything to share about correct how's
craig doing yeah i know we were joking
about hair earlier but i mean all
kidding aside
craig craig's hair looks fantastic so
enjoy old clean shaven craig while you
still can because craig is looking
craig's looking sharp these days all
right so i want to i want to keep you
longer than we need to we got a lot of
work to get done clearly but before we
go just any final kind of closing
thoughts you would like to share with
the community today yeah i mean look we
know expectations for this game are are
high um for for us in the studio and for
fans especially in this 20th anniversary
year of xbox and halo i just want
everyone to know that we're we're
working hard we're having fun and we
really want to say thank you for your
you know your passion and your feedback
and when when you push us um these kinds
of conversations are are great and i
love having them we're super excited for
launch and we hope all our fans are too
well thanks joseph uh you know again
also from me and community team and the
whole studio truly thank you to our
community just the passion and the
unwavering support and understanding has
been
just
inspirational especially through some
some difficult times um i am super
excited about our upcoming technical
preview as a reminder if you want an
opportunity to go hands-on with halo
infinite multiplayer help us test the
game for launch give us more feedback
kick the tires on our brand new big team
battle bigger and better than ever go to
haloinsider.com anyone can sign up just
a couple quick steps to jump through
we'll be having a bigger and better tech
preview coming up um and additionally
you know it sounds like we've got a lot
of stuff on the horizon this is a
journey that's just beginning
and uh we need some folks to help us so
if you're watching this and you've got
the skills please go to
343industries.com
check out our latest career openings uh
we are always looking to bring more
people in to help us build the future of
halo so
thank you very much for watching today
stay tuned be sure to follow halo on
twitter keep tabs on hilahwaypoint.com
we'll have a lot more to say and show in
the very near future thank you very much
you